le talent exceptionnel et tu restes avec
nous mais cela je vais te mettre face à
l'actu tu as suivi un petit peu la main
sur va forcément tirer que tu as vu tout
ce qui se passe dans le monde c'est
incroyable en ce moment toi tu es séries
comme disait eric naulleau tintin
philosophe aussi un taxiway sans rire
parce que j'en compte tout ce qu'il dit
en vrai il ya une vérité it ain t séries
que tout ce qui se passe en ce moment ça
t'a fait flipper moment toutes ces
histoires de kobe de de paris c'est
triste parce que les gens sont dans un
sens c'est bon c'est pas bon dans un
sens au compromis
on comprend maintenant ce que c'est la
liberté la loi
ces agents sortent ils se retrouvent
donc moi j'ai plus de chance que
d'autres but que je sais je sais mieux
enfin je sait voyager et développement
mais j'ai beaucoup voyagé je suis pas
tellement eu peur du comité j'essaye de
l'ignorer et cette année c'est un avis
un investissement c'est le dernier
avertissement je crois de la nature et
pour faire attention mais avec l'âge ce
qui se passe dans la planète et tout ça
non mais c'est alors est ce que le monde
sera meilleur après le coït c'est ton
premier face à face face à la q tu es
face à fabrice di vizio qui rendent tout
à mettre 10 millions c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
m ça coûte à l'état pur y est il a une
baisse de tapper fabrique je t'aime
frère de jean claude
ouais ouais fabrice di vizio grand
avocat au chômage en cause non mais t'as
vu ton public sans il est certain c'est
que grâce à ce que fabrice di vizio pour
qu'il aime quelque chose
non mais c'est à part le tiramisu jean
claude van damme le monde sera-t-il
meilleur après le coc vide jean-claude
toi tu pense aussi que toutes ces
restrictions tout ce qui s'est passé ça
peut faire comprendre conscience aux
gens aussi de voilà du monde dans lequel
on vit qui est magnifique et de se dire
que les plaisirs simples va s est il
faut va les retrouver et que c'est vrai
que ça nous a mis une claque ce que
vides en fait c'est que ça nous a fait
prendre conscience de plein de choses
mais à 2 il ya une inversion tu es mon
poteau de mon ami dans la version tv
peut parler les gens vont s'en sortir
bien tout ça bon l'inversé pourrait
retrouver puis tu as la version on n'est
qu'à ma mère ya pas mal de monde sous la
terre et on essaie de millions de gens
numéro un numéro bien milliards c'est
sevani milliards de gens des vaccins le
différents pays et puis à des des zones
rouges des zones vertes des zones rouges
de nouveaux verte pas voyager c'est très
bien fait c'est très matic m'en parle on
s'est formidablement bien fait et je
m'arrête de parler o sinon ça va partir
en cacahuète tabriz jing est ce que le
monde sera meilleur après covin le monde
y sera ce qu'on en fera merci fabrice
salle
t'es sûr très donc il n'y a pas de
déterminisme le monde sera ce qu'on en
fera et en fait on a les portes ouvertes
maintenant c'est nous qui choisissons de
savoir lesquels ont franchi ou non ont
cessé en fait il ya des leçons à tirer
de l'histoire tout le temps la question
ces soirées ce qu'on veut le faire et
est ce qu'on sera capable de le faire et
quand il ya jean fautrier c'est le
dernier avertissement il ya pas mal de
gens qui pensent comme god je vous dis
qu'il y c'est le dernier avertissement
c'est c'est vraiment un signal fort il
va falloir faire attention
qu'est ce que vous dites est ce que dit
donc que c'est un avertissement est ce
que c'est le dernier j'en sais rien mais
qui est un avertissement oui c'est
certain maintenant avertissement sur
quoi de quoi
mais moi ce que je trouve tout à fait
remarquable dans cette histoire c'est
qu'au fond dans ce que vides on a côtoyé
le meilleur et le pire en fait à la pire
et le meilleur
le meilleur ça a été aussi ses soignants
qu'on a applaudi en mars dernier ça
aussi ça a été aussi ses élans de
générosité simple de la part des gens
voilà alors le pire on sait mais je
pense qu'il faut aussi parler de ce
meilleur et que c'est ce meilleur qu'il
faut garder finalement demandant dans
l'avenir on va on va vers un jour sans
kobe d'où ça va être serré on va on va
de presse avec le probable
c'est peu probable aujourd'hui tout
porte à croire que finalement on va
entrer dans une dans une saisonnalité du
virus tout le monde commence à le penser
et je crois que le zéro co vide c'est
quelque chose qui maintenant est
derrière nous c'est incontestable tous
les pays qui l'ont fait marche pas quoi
vous allez vous faire vous êtes fait
vacciner finalement pas et toi jean côté
fait vacciner pas du tout pas du tout
non pour l'instant qu'à ton job jamais
tu l'as vu toi tu as été peut-être a eu
la copie ou pas n'ont pour l'instant pas
encore d'accord tu fais tu fais
attention je n'ai pas demain ce que
c'est pas bien de dire ça mais je
raisonne en fin juillet à l'intérieur de
plus en plus de gens disent que c'est
peu on peut ne touchait pas les fabrique
moi qu'il faut vivre avec ce virus
on n'a pas le choix on ne sait pas
d'éviter numéro 2
il faut le sport c'est bien si je peux
donner des concerts etc mais sert à
faire du sport c'est bien et voilà un
iphone itouch cheval conduite économique
mon père était cohabitent à 85 ans il a
reçu ce qu'il fallait ce qui était
supprimée il a reçu ce qu'il fallait du
smac je veux dire et alors il a pris ce
qu'il fallait et après 10 jours et les
reparti sur sa bicyclette et bientôt
vous allez fêter les soixante huit ans
de voilà mes parents seront en 68 ans
marié lahouel nov
[Applaudissements]